Hi.
I'd like to announce my new book beyond order 12 more rules for
life, which I've.
Been working on diligently for the past three years.
As of today,
the book is available for pre-order in the U S the UK and Canada.
I've linked to some major retailers,
including international links for Amazon in the videos description below.
I've also included the link to the beyond order page on my website,
Jordan B peterson.com,
where links to book retailers in different countries will be posted as they
become available beyond order will also be published as an
ebook and as an audio book, which I have nearly finished recording,
all formats will be released on Tuesday, March 2nd, 2020.
Yeah.
I want to provide you with a sense of the book in addition to announcing its
existence. So I thought I would read you a section from the overture,
the introduction, which describes the book's contents.
Detail
beyond order 12 more rules for life.
Why beyond order, it is simple. In some regard.
Order is explored territory.
We are in order when the actions we deem appropriate produce the results we aim
at,
we regard such outcomes positively indicating as they do first,
that we have moved closer to what we desire. And second,
that our theory about how the world works remains acceptably accurate.
Nonetheless.
All States of order, no matter how secure and comfortable have their flaws.
Are knowledge.
Of how to act in the world remains eternally incomplete,
partly because of our profound ignorance of the vast unknown,
partly because of our willful blindness.
And partly because the world continues in its in Tropic manner to transform
itself unexpectedly.
Furthermore.
The order we strive to impose on the world can rigidified as a consequence of
ill-advised attempts to eradicate from consideration, all that is unknown.
When such attempts go too far,
totalitarianism threatens driven by the desire to exercise full control
where such control is not possible.
Even in principle, this means.
A dangerous restriction of all the psychological and social changes necessary to
maintain adaptation to the ever-changing world.
And so we find ourselves in escapable faced with the need to move beyond order
into itself.
Opposite chaos, if order.
Where what we want makes itself known when we act in accordance with our hard
won wisdom, chaos is where,
what we do not expect to remain blind to leaps forward from the potential that
surrounds us.
The fact that something has occurred many times in the past is no guarantee that
it will continue to occur in the same manner.
There exists eternally a domain beyond what we know and.
Can predict chaos is.
A normally novelty, unpredictability,
transformation disruption, and all too often descent.
As what we have come to take for granted reveals itself is unreliable.
Sometimes.
It manifests itself gently revealing its mysteries and experience that makes us
curious, compelled and interested. This is particularly likely,
although not inevitable when we approach what we do not understand voluntarily
with careful preparation and discipline.
Other times the unexpected makes itself known terribly suddenly
accidentally.
So we are undone and fall apart and can only put ourselves back together with
great difficulty.
If at all.
Neither the state of order nor the state of chaos is preferable intrinsically.
The other that is the wrong way to look at it. Nonetheless.
In my previous book, 12 rules for life, an antidote to chaos,
I focus more on how the consequences of too much chaos might be remediated.
We respond to sudden and unpredictable change by preparing physiologically and
psychologically for the worst.
And because only God himself knows what this worst might be.
We must in our ignorance prepare for all eventualities.
And the problem with that continual preparation is that in excess,
it exhausts us,
but that does not imply in any manner that chaos should be eliminated an
impossibility in any case,
although what is unknown needs to be managed carefully as my previous book,
repeatedly.
Stressed, whatever.
Is not touched by the new stagnates. And it is certainly the case that a life,
without curiosity,
that instinct pushing us out into the unknown would be a much diminished form of
existence. What is new is also what is exciting, compelling,
and provocative.
Assuming that the rate at which it is introduced does not intolerably undermine
and destabilize our state.
Of being.
Like 12 rules for life.
The current volume provides an explication of rules drawn from a longer list of
42, originally published and popularized on the Q and a website Quora,
unlike my previous book, beyond order explorers as its overarching theme,
how the dangers of too much security and control might be profitable.
Really avoided because what we understand is insufficient.
As we discover when things we are striving to control, nonetheless,
go wrong around us.
We need to keep one foot within order while stretching the other tentatively
into the.
Beyond. And so.
We are driven to explore and find the deepest of meanings in standing on the
frontier, secure enough to keep our fear under control,
but learning constantly learning as we face.
What we have not yet made peace with or adapted.
To it is this instinct.
Of meaning something far deeper than mere thought that orients us properly in
life so that we do not become overwhelmed by what is beyond us or equally
dangerously stultified and stunted by dated too narrow or too
prideful, fully paraded systems of value.
Belief.
What have I written about more specifically.
One describes the relationship between stable,
predictable social structures and individual psychological health and makes the
case that such structures need to be updated by creative people.
If they are to retain their vitality.
Rule.
Two analyzes, a centuries old L chemical image, relying on several stories,
ancient and modern to aluminate,
the nature and development of the integrated human personality
Rule three warns of the dangers of avoiding the information vital to the
continued rejuvenation of the psyche signaled by the emergence of negative
emotions, such as pain, anxiety, and fear.
Rule.
Four argues that the meaning that sustains people through difficult times is to
be found not so much in happiness, which is fleeting,
but in the voluntary adoption of mature responsibility for the self.
And others rule.
Five uses a single example drawn from my experience as a clinical
psychologist to illustrate the personal and social necessity of attending to the
dictates of conscience.
Rule six describes the danger of attributing,
the cause of complex individual and social problems to single variables
such as sex.
Class or power rules.
Seven outlines,
the crucial relationship between disciplines striving in a single direction and
forging of the individual character capable of resilience in the face.
Adversity rule eight.
Focuses on the vital importance of aesthetic experience as a guide to what is
true, good and sustaining in the human world of experience.
Rule nine makes the case that past experiences whose current recall remains
Laden with pain and fear can be stripped of their horror by voluntary verbal
exploration and reconsideration.
Okay.
Rule 10 notes,
the importance of explicit negotiation to maintenance of the Goodwill mutual
regard and heartfelt cooperation without which no true romance can be
sustained.
Rule 11 opens by describing the world of human experience in a manner that
explains what motivates three common,
but direly dangerous patterns of psychological response, delineates,
the catastrophic consequences of falling prey to any or all of them and lays out
an alternative.
Route. Rule 12 finally.
Makes the case that thankfulness in the face of the inevitable tragedies of life
should be regarded as a primary manifestation of the admirable moral courage
required to continue our difficult March uphill.
I hope that I am somewhat wiser in my explication of this second set of 12 rules
than I was four years ago.
When I wrote about the first dozen not least because of the informative feedback
I received in the course of my efforts to formulate my ideas for audiences
around the world, in person on YouTube and through my podcast and blog.
I hope in consequence that I have managed to clarify some of the issues that
were perhaps left less than optimally developed in my previous work,
as well as presenting much. That is original. Finally,
I hope that people find this book as helpful personally,
as they seem to have found the first set of 12 rules,
it has been a source of immense gratification that so many people have reported
drawing strength from the thoughts and the stories I have had the privilege of
bringing forth and sharing.
That was the second half of the overture from beyond order 12 more
rules for life. Once again,
the book in all its forms will be published March 2nd,
2021 links for pre-sale are posted in the description below.
Thank you from the bottom of my heart,
for your interest in and support of my work.